[Musica]
questo è un bel discorso
bene a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo video sono fa vj ed oggi il
topos tecniche mi sembra incredibile
siamo ritornati sul gap simulator gay
non lo sarà da stavo aspettando questo
momento da tanto tempo ritrovato ragazzi
è piaciuto un casino quindi vi ringrazio
di cuore perché a volte non lo so la
ritrova anche il papa e quindi ragazzi
dire che un secondo episodio ci sta
tutto è entrato non ho fatto un casino
di cose perché poi mi sono informato ci
sono un miliardo di cose da fare che non
ho fatto sono contentissimo michia
ritorna mi mancava tutto mi mancava
qualsiasi cosa ha debuttato di una capra
perfetto di giorno non vedevo l'ora di
buongiorno è una cosa sono contento kat
non contento perché da secoli che poi ho
visto la morte in faccia tu che cazzo
corri bastardo a vini quadrato fieni
colle che avete consigliato da questo
tizio qui che a togliti dai [ __ ]
faccio io è un discorso serio
ragazzi questo è per voi perché chi mi
ama mi segue in questo cammino
porca [ __ ] che casa successo calmi
alcuno per voi
quello è svenuto a caso ragazzi che
cazzo succede ne è rimasto soltanto uno
è bello questo va bè ragazzi non importa
l'inter perfetto l'altro ragazzi mi è
rimasto soltanto uno pochi ma buoni
senti mi presti di cartello
è venuto anche lui volevo soltanto fare
politica non mi sembra una cosa così
difficile ci riescono le capre ole ole
via chiabotto che è perfetto
ragazzi ho trovato un nuovo sport del
lancio del piatto è una cosa pazzesca è
un'arma letale quest'altro che bomba
atomica basta mi sono mangiato se
stronzate lega non avete amici voleva un
clock simulator per forza dopo dopotutto
st pausa di partire con questo è il
massimo una cosa chi che senso cosa no
ska kat gab kat
aveva la vermi tu non puoi passare ma
che cazzo mi piaceva
buon compleanno adesso ragazzi dopo
tanto tempo ho capito perché non mi
invitano alle feste c'era un motivo alla
fine comunque trovare ragazzi c'è
un'altra cosa che volevo fare che non
avevo fatto che devo veramente questo è
come questo qua non l'avevo scoperto
l'altra volta print e se ci porti 55
tipi 5 tizi così dovresti diventare
satana in persona credo che i ragazzi
dovrei essere dopo dopo secoli
[ __ ] rega è normale e normale che
si che cazzo è successo for the globe
yacht ci siamo già con diventato una
capra una capra satanica se io tremo è
un cazzo ok per me è ok
e andato tutto a [ __ ] fantastico
fallisce voglio scendere e un aereo e
superman
no è una cazzo di capra che vola caso le
perfette perfetto è stata è stata
l'emozione più grande della mia vita
tra l'altro siamo tornati qui non so
perché non dovrebbe essere questo in
teoria il potere che cioè ecco infatti
sarebbe quello di i primi terra ancora
un po a tutto quello che riesco a
mettere insieme fantastico ho trovato
dopo secoli il modo per rimettere a
posto camera mia in modo decente cazzo
che prima cosa bella riga che se premuto
e poi premo r ecco infatti è una cosa
stupenda
io non voglio non voglio neanche non
voglio sapere perché fa così
ma è una figata assurda a questo che
cazzo non questo nuovo dove sono finito
the wonder science che sono diventato
una capra offesa ragazzi sono diventato
obeso
perché è che son diventato che si sta
roba non c'era prima adesso forse posso
buttare giù le macchine mi sastre ferma
stronzo r no non posso farlo ugualmente
ragazzi sono diventato una capra
satanica obesa a caso non so perché lato
c'è un oscar su stock option ma è un
tunnel
qual è il senso di stoccaggio e mi butto
dentro caso se sono diventato minuscolo
adesso sono diventate un nano una capra
nana satanica fantastico se adesso ecco
lo sapevo
rimango gigante perché mi piaceva di più
comunque non lo so come cazzo è
possibile con craxi ecco questo questo
ragazzi sarà la cosa più bella che
vedrete nella vostra vice questa è
un'arena di capre vinto cazzo macabro
bianca nella cappella più potente ma
[ __ ] devi morire e devi morire non
è allora sei stronzo e come cazzo fa
essere così potente che più piccola di
me ma [ __ ] mi sembra l'equivalente
di rey mysterio contro big sean round 4
ma vieni trans ma sei stronzo allora e
di morire
devi morire e devi ma quello che basta
fa essere così potente una gara
adesso chi a marchi una bottai da
mazzotta tuo fratello tua sorella ma
[ __ ] muori
magari non è possesso ragazzi non è mai
la donna una donna non si bastardo
potente donna d'onna modo ma [ __ ]
e di morire devi morire e devi è caduto
è caduto fuori ma guarda che è
impossibile che cazzo ma a [ __ ] sia
rallenterà le t bravo bravo bravo
un piano o un piano che può funzionare
non so se può funzionare ci provo
ce l'ho fatta sono finito su un ramo
allora sono riuscito a tornare con la
capra normale perché allora sei stronzo
netto buttarti giù in nessun modo
ma che cazzo ci sono dovuto tornare
normale ma non ci riesco uguale allora
sei bastardo morrissey si fan culo ce
l'ho fatta ho fatta sì dov'è andata
persa doppia esse ragazzi dove sono io
sono diventato hulk sono diventata una
capra geneticamente modificata di brutto
ben diventato una capra della madonna
adesso forse ce la faccio a buttar giù
quello sotto pranzo di merda è niente
come ragazzi sono diventato ultim
persona voglio vedere se madonna come
sculetta voglio vedere se ok la macchina
non si ferma questo l'ho capito adesso
il trampolino in pieno quasi in qualche
modo la fermo regata noto un piano non
so se può funzionare ma c'è un piano e
credo che l'abbiate intuito tutti se
riesco e non lo so a franco sul tetto
mica contro cassaforte st capra che
diciamo andare le pietre non è proprio
un sassolino diciamo allora vai così ai
vai vai bene
sì sì sì già posso fare ce la posso fare
ebbene si se sto ca va a cagare stronza
eccolo che ci sia ma affanculo tutto è
una cosa qua dentro ragazzi non ce l'ho
ancora arrivato venite puoi fare skate
con le capre ero puparo gli skater melo
buffon che gli è intorno a [ __ ]
mancato il cerchio perché pronti ragazzi
questo questo ve lo ricorderete di
sicuro che non sono venuto ma non era
con intento a na na na na detta te che
cazzo sta facendo i ragazzi e bellissima
tutto quello che avete imparato in
fisica o che imparerete se non l'avete
ancora fatta sono puttanate
è questo la è questa la fisica ragazzi
io darei un nobel a questa capra non so
perché io ve l'ho detto più gioco a sta
roba
io mi chiedo che cosa sto facendo della
mia vita perché non è possibile che
iorio non lo speck dove cazzo siamo
finiti sul te cos'è [ __ ] cielo
quasi eccola lì
[Musica]
ok ok vai nicchia che mira di merda
delimitare per caso ma è vai giù cazzo
mar da lì ce l'ho fatta non ci posso ho
fatto un salto che non guarda lì che
potenza ragazzi che sculetta fa i salti
migliori questo è garantito e fantastico
eccolo lì poggiare una signora c'è
michele cibo per capra da qualche parte
qui non lo so perché salve buon gioco lo
so che lei è molto affettuoso 6 intatto
bisogno di trovare del cibo perché a
premessa perché si indica
vabbè facciamo finta di a e qui a grazie
comunque ragazzi got simulator io ve lo
dico è uno dei giochi più spettacolari
che io abbia mai giocato perché per
questo per questo perché non ho altre
spiegazioni non so che cazzo dirvi di
altro e spettacolare volevo anche
chiedervi se volete che lo continui
perché ci sono un miliardo di altre cose
che voglio farvi vedere anche con le
mode perché non scaricate alcune che
sono splendide voglio fare nei prossimi
episodi
va bè ragazzi come pensavo di vedere se
riesco ad aggrapparmi a quel cazzo di
deltaplano che non ci sono mai riuscito
e devo allora fermi fermi che arriva
[Musica]
[Applauso]
l'ho preso al primo tentano ci posso
credere non ci grazie ragazzi se l'ho
fatta e con questo direi che ai ragazzi
che con questo comunque posso concludere
qui perché cielo ho provato di tutto c'è
un casino di altre cose comunque da
farvi vedere perché ci sono stravolte
altro ci sono un miliardo di cose che
ancora non ho fatto ma da oggi si
riprende seriamente a fare video
normalmente quindi spero siate contenti
non sono anch'io perché ero in astinenza
cazzo punti ragazzi dire che possono
includere qui mentre la capra si sbatte
da una parte all'altra lasciato mi piace
servito è piaciuto anche la pagina di
facebook e come non i video parata nella
descrizione ad essere onesti iscrivetevi
ci rivediamo nel prossimo vinto belle
ragazze